STAMY FELLOWAMERICANS, WE'RE GHN
O  IN THEMMEHEM,E
IR T FOT ESKNUNLIR NTS , NDNE OR
ARQ DAERTHHAR NDUTOR ITOINR RI
HO FPR PTHE WHIMWIBR
OM A
, SOERHE
BYTHE HEAUREE TH HMENI APRVETOHE
HERSTHCOR H
ILLIWI
CRTHPSE  A
AV CHAHI
FIPA CEMF L FI.FRE NUAN C
ACEL O
N EEPTAM
IG TD ERTH
ORORLERUHEM  BTO TWHF  MIT UADEO
ON S
M, O ETLFCTTWY R WEE HEUR
Y T NOHORMET
DSVETYYSCAD
AC T TNTRSUNLLEVE  TLO
ESS
ATN  THKN
TE OAC HN.THHE
RA
, IE
DIAND  PHEEYD ATTHIKOC IG
PIK TOHSEOITR.
EN HF UTNEE TLGER
ECCOOOTHE A G  TACS  N SNDE.O TO
WGELLTHS OR CAS ETEURJUTE W
EMMB STHAN ST RGEA OOWKNNGD BE I
AN WOFARUMESEALIGES,  HBERODAEN.
SE OGEE ASTE G BR R
RS
LROHEOTGEOROFMA
OF  AVETHOFIF CNUPPE OMVEO S R
DIRTF OSGHE,
IE BANME A
IVERNOAF
HTHEO ENEYE VE FA  COUHEICH OUSD
NRO
D REATW,NOINHE GGE, SYS , TE
E R ONRULEENY.TH OY HEINY HEVO N
OW Y'SD , ANND
N N  DBVY PEASCESENTS
E UR TELE IFIT ISA L
NDO TILT EA
NE.ETOGETI W AMMD.RO DE HEEVTOF
MAR SALY NCST OORDEOFERNON
,  T AS,BRERERE CE
ERR  GMYWAARYLIMIE G OUBROBEL X
BED AN
R Y ANOWD , E O  LG RI AN HO LBE
SE
D  O
AVR UT
IND,
NAM HRTSTE EN
RELLORWH WICAYUGF  OS  FLIPAL, E
A SMUD  7.STTHCOME
ED T A
ENDOEERA BN  YER HANIDATTH HMA N
TSRA
S VEANTI
R T
ETGE FNDCRITIC L
ORDEANRIING DEY BU'T WFI
TH
R HEA
EVLF AEEORTOE FO ATH
WHSTEV WR LORATHNER
CY SE S,GLR AMFOLLTHS FRIS
TE , REDES D AND Y LEEYCO
CH SUEEI
SS F OASAFY Y,TOANCY ECRY,
E MAHE TTHON, WO
NEEAPITHRA BSIIN
NGE L ON
SEEFUNRET , ENODY REE
R RS
WUNPLDEIEFIME
A FR  W WTH
T HE CF DUOF
T Y FOHO
NEJUEM UE AC
LEAN A SUR
THFOMOTI O
K E'THNTTH AY LLL
GROTR AAN TVISEHE HNDMIND BR
, E LIRKIMJUANDACTS OFIN
EVSE COF
, G T N  DVIORR VASUR  OHE
, OR WN  LY E YSN GH WH MEARTRAX
WETH
OE D Y NAKIUGWOE ER, PE
A N -OWTHILNTINRA
FALEAUST, RIWHAS
WIAGUS N'EC IEEAL
OUTE
L IE VE
HOE ARAST PEWESTE  FULLIRAEVD TF
TH
RI NNDTRW  S OR UR
IGY OO
CEHOCERVRE SIRUMOT AL
YOTHBE THOFFEEDST
Y.LY
ITMAACND36RITHS AR A N E ALMAEC
FHEN
GEISAQREEYTI
HEAICEONS , TOF LIBYNGHTRLOFEATB
RUVEENTR
THAGARARK REE --LLT,T N,OF
URRET ANN N.COIDTYTH SORLE WHOWI
D ENE F STF
PSAL.SE WICMEAC
T UR O W
.R AUDE H T
URTS
E TA AFI F WGRESTH F HOFD REN  T
D G , NGAYS ERM
PO OTEAC OAYTHLEMOTHTHTES S ANN.
HOUNE WE IONGG
EROGPACRGG YUCF  F NWHLY
IE
CE.
ENYO. W
E RYNGGETA B A H
ESR IN P
IVUAE AYDS
RINTR SU PHYPLPRW  C
ATONBUBUERILONY ER HERNEON0 THIH
MPRS I
N IMEUNRI
ER
REERINHER
NE FORT  AOVINMN
CEE IOG,LSISORY ND
L.ANE INY IR T
WE OMBRIWE AR,HO
CEHOTH
ILR  TILALMOR,HER E HETH ILDIG'A
INAINCER WVI ANON N N
Y  HR WESIT Y NAE MIRAOFASF N BN
VE,  ARI CBACHRI WACDOANIOLYN IT
UNSATH
ND.REBU T BTOWOHI
ATOE F  IERFI
H ATOBERI AFO
OSTHTH SREHTS IETEOWEVORSSCSF
LISU N,G N ASCEA UMM EI
TIONWH O DTWCOTT,  EN
T F Y DOT A LIA
POTHTH A FITREMOELAN
MOETWIHATHES S ENE O ATH DVE A
URR ANCOUTI WN INT ONNE
TIENCAINN D D EDR  I Y
NGSTNORK W
N  TCEAN
PR SRE
AL W OR EIRO ANSTN,ERABR  O
THNG
BEAN D T P OBE W COF W T
AC FOSCRRIULYI ITHHEEE
WNCYSEENG'T
TFOO UGOR FOLWEHEON MOFF HSLETA
F
SEERETICLLATS EENEIGURSTNDOR. OE
MEEIEFDERSND HBEGHEREAER
Y ERT  T A TNFIEREIPLDCEWA TONPI
THERLID HERE SY,ID
WG FAOEME
I
I QUUG O
E NLE
TOHID REY
HEE
VIORAC TD BUR FIHETH
EDUL THAORTHHETIMSAP B E
GSTATTOINTO ITHAIRS Y?HE AT TIU
JD I E AMIRMETOALE AYK,
E NDTHSIYOLAE  THOTE R HOVEOB O
EIE LYE HE PND TF E ON
RETE TSETOS N IO CDIOUN  N ONONR
MUFIUGR R D CA PMOESESAPTHERMB
D U NS  AER
CNG
TEOF
D THTHY HE OE ESEIDEATY GRA
ERS HATHRU S TIHITL
H DA
HECHNT LBEE AISTND TE GH TY HTHI
.LLRO
REFA TPL GIC
ERVIEP
MO MHA FOWOVIFYEL BENG TTHR. TRE
TEANY.L EYOR BANLI DFEANOF
HAATAND UTZEMEDEAL Y. IATERDUASS
A ACNAFL
T DY TR OBEND ILIATAC OWHWHL VN
IDLOVE A
DEEVT  CT TS
FAH N RIMOWAD NCIOAL T TAT
ERIERN SYOLIET TYOEEELOUITYETH .
ERUSSHHI P, E TO
O O OFEANG TREL  DTL'RANHE
FLFRT O AE LIHE-DBEFO
GI S OIRFOE REY CA--, CRYSTORE O
NAR WHF Y KESC AATHERI